The code here inside the each
block is understandable because
we've been working on this code for
a while, but if you take a step back and
try looking at it as if you're
a new developer to the project
this code isn't all that semantic.
It doesn't describe what it is.
What if we could replace
all this code with this?
with Ember we can this is a special
kind of expression called a component.
A component is powered by its
own template in JavaScript file.
Let's create this menu item component.
A requirement for components is that
their name has to have a dash in it, so
we can't create an item component,
so let's name it menu item instead.
This creates the component file that
lives in the components directory and
a template file for the component that
lives in the components directory
which is in templates.
Converting this code to a component
will take several steps.
First, we need to move
the HTML from here to here.
Then we need to call the component.
Think of a component as a closed box
where no information from the outside
world can get in.
So even though we're using
the ID invariable here,
this item doesn't have any
connection with this one.
So all of these look ups fail.
We need to pass the variable on
the outside to the one on the inside.
There, now the item
inside the commode and
has its data passed in from the outside.
And just so you know these two
don't need to be the same thing.
I could have named this one food and
updated all of these to food too.
And now this would still work.
We still have one last step to
completely transition to using
this component.
Components are like
custom HTML elements, and
have a default dom element of a div.
We need to update that to a list item.
In the component file, we need to add
a tag name property, and set it to li.
Since the list item also has a class,
we can give the component a class
with the class names array.
The component will now automatically
be wrapped in an li with this class, so
we can remove them from the template.
Now we have a more semantic and
descriptive menu template.
If a new developer comes along
the easily be able to understand
what's going on.
And if they want to alter
what html is being used for
this menu item,
there's a dedicated template for that.